there is new political chaos in Spain
this morning the country's Prime
Minister called on the government to
approve direct rule over Catalonia the
move follows the region's disputed vote
for independence earlier this month
Seth Doane is in Barcelona that's
Catalonia is capital south good morning
good morning it may seem quiet out in
front of the Parliament but inside the
building behind me catalonia's
Parliament an intense debate is underway
as we speak they are looking at whether
they may declare independence
finally and outside these gates you have
supporters who have gathered it has the
feeling of a kind of mix between a
protest and a sort of street party you
see people with the flags that have been
adopted by the independence movement
here in Catalonia people wearing
democracy logos people saying that they
are protecting the Parliament supporters
gathered around it cheering on
parliamentarians and mayors as they come
in to listen to this key vote on the
other side of course this morning we had
Prime Minister Mariano Rajoy the prime
minister of Spain who made an
impassioned speech in front of Spain's
Senate he was trying to make the
argument for article 155 that never
before a used piece of Spain's
Constitution which would allow for
direct rule here in Catalonia he said it
was important to restore law and order
here and also democracy one of the
things that would come with that if
Mariano Rajoy gets his way is you would
see some of the top leaders in Catalonia
sacked they would see the President of
the Catalonian region lose his job and
the Parliament here
lose some of their power there is a
great deal of fear all of this
surrounding the violence that sparked
around that October first referendum and
today you find people outside around
Parliament not far from where I'm
standing now who really worry about
Spain coming in and imposing direct rule
and some separatist leaders Noora have
vowed civil disobedience if indeed Spain
enters an important story there Seth
Doane in Barcelona thank you